women in afghanistan will be allowed to
study in female only classrooms and the
subjects they take will also be reviewed
they will also have to wear a hijab when
attending classes these are part of a
new higher education policy announced by
the taliban over the weekend a policy
some fear could further exclude women
from public life
the taliban came to announce the new
rules for women and higher education to
a room filled almost exclusively with
men
in future there will be no mixing of the
sexes
and the subjects women are allowed to
study could also be restricted
we don't want co-education and we've
designed a structure to end co-education
in afghanistan higher education
institutes have agreed with that plan
and they're implementing it
the taliban say their decision is in
line with islam
but critics say segregating the sexes
represents a break with the past
and will be difficult for practical
reasons
such as a lack of female professors
with the result that fewer women end up
attending university
[Applause]
women in favor of change however also
mobilized over the weekend
they said they welcomed the islamic
emirate and criticized the anti-taliban
protest led by women in recent weeks but
their message was also that under islam
women have not only the right to study
but also to work and to inherit from
their families
we want to be given the rights that
islam assigns to us
we are muslims and we want rights that
islam has given us
not the rights that westerners impose on
us
[Music]
now they and others are waiting to see
if the taliban's interpretation of islam
will live up to their expectations
and joining me for more is vastly nazimi
head of the afghan service at dw vasla
given the state of educational resources
in afghanistan today can women and men
be segregated at universities
well bearish in theory afghan women and
men of course can be segregated but we
must ask what this practically means for
afghan women there are not enough
facilities in every afghan university
and there are by far not enough
professors and teachers who could
maintain teaching them separately this
means that the quality of education will
decrease significantly the taliban have
said that in some cases there will be
the possibility of male professors
teaching women behind a curtain or via
video calls
but on top of that we also have to ask
what will this these women do with their
diplomas once they have finished
university will they be able to work in
their respective fields whether this is
a long-term solution this remains to be
seen
have women in afghanistan reached out to
you with concerns over these new rules
there are women who are concerned and
who are worried about these developments
because they fear that this is the
beginning of a downward spiral and
slowly taking away more and more of the
freedoms they possessed before but there
are also women who are relieved they
will be able to keep on pursuing an
education even under the previous
government not all women were able to
attend university because of family
restrictions or security reasons and for
some families the harassment that women
had to endure at university was enough
reason to not send their daughters to
university for these families it might
actually mean more freedom there are
different perspectives on this and all
are valid
and you spoke of a downward spiral now i
wonder therefore if the taliban you
think are using these rules as a cover
potentially to exclude women from
society
um i'm not so sure about that i think
it's
it's actually one step ahead of what we
were using from the taliban in the 90s
but of course this shouldn't be our
standard if wearing a cloth was what
what it takes for women to be free and
receive an education i think that would
be something that afghan women could put
up for discussion but most women don't
believe that they will stop at this and
yet at the same time we hear reports of
women being beaten and whipped on the
streets we hear of killings of former
government employees and this is of
grave concern for women rights activists
can afghanistan actually make any
progress if women aren't included wholly
in
the
in various public spheres such as in
work and education
well according to the taliban they want
to include women in accordance of
islamic law a few days ago we had no
idea what that actually meant but slowly
it has become more clear what they are
implying by this and it's a version of
islam that is foreign to afghans yes in
many parts of afghanistan especially in
rural areas women have always been
excluded and for those this might even
look like progress but we have to look
at the country as a whole and the
taliban cannot ignore those women who
have been enjoying more freedom and were
able to work in various fields outside
their homes right now only health and
education sectors are permitted and they
can also not ban afghan women who are
artists who have contributed immensely
to afghan society
we'll leave it there for the time being
but thanks so much for joining us today
you